thank you
may have seen footage this past week of
unrecord it's a new FPS game from a body
cam perspective that's insanely
realistic but to some people it crosses
a dangerous line who wants to play a
shooter this realistic it just becomes
uncomfortable I've seen that take from a
few people and I actually completely
understand where that's coming from
because this looks like actual footage
the people you're shooting look like
real people it looks like it's not
filmed
[Music]
okay so in April 19th French game
developer Alexander Spindler posted
footage to Twitter of a game he'd been
working on called unrecord along with a
link to its steam page since posting the
video it now has over 12 million views
and if you've seen just a second of it
you know exactly why that is
shots fired shots fired
but before we talk about how some people
might find this game dangerous we need
to talk about the fact that many doubted
it was even real people said it was
scripted or an on-rails game and a few
even suggested it was an animation in
response Alexander posted footage of the
game in his Unreal Engine 5 session in
it he drops himself into two different
spots on the map and lets off a few
pistol rounds at random despite this
some people still think there's no real
game here or at the very least that this
is only a proof of concept Tech demo and
won't reflect the actual game most
people were citing The Uncanny Valley
movement of the hands as one of their
issues I saw a few people on Twitter
even suggest that this was some big
brain move they knew that people would
say the game was fake so they
pre-recorded more Clips to make it seem
like they were just spontaneously
dropping into the game now as funny as
that would be I doubt it's the case
because as many of you probably remember
this isn't even the first time we've
actually seen this game back in October
of last year Alexander posted a similar
albeit less polished clip which sparked
similar reactions on top of that the
maps that were used in the pieces of
footage are assets that are available
for purchase on the unreal Marketplace
and a few people have shown off that
looks like minus the whole body cam
first person shooter aspect when it
comes to the almost exaggerated hand
movements the devs state that the game
features unrestricted free Aim so my
guess is that they've just been trying
to show off that mechanic as much as
possible but even among those who
accepted it was real some felt the game
was almost too real and they posed a
very simple question
have we gone too far if you just showed
me that video as I was scrolling through
Twitter I'd 100 think I was on live leak
it really does look like you're just
watching real footage of someone getting
into a gunfight but it's not it is a
game as a result there are some people
who think that the ultra realism can
have a negative effect on susceptible
people and lead to negative consequences
like real life violence which might
sound familiar for those that don't know
people have been using video games as a
scapegoat for violence for a very very
long time since the original doom and
Wolfenstein 3D there's always been
campaigns to try and push the blame onto
violent video games in an effort to get
them banned and while violence in video
games can alter one's mood or cause
anxiety there's never been any credible
evidence to support the claim that
violence in a video game leads to
violence in real life regardless of that
fact many countries have banned certain
video games over the years strictly
based on their violence and although
it's become much more of a moot point
recently the conversation still pops up
now and again and it's usually
associated to the game's level of
realism which is exactly what's going on
right now with on record hell even train
wrecks chimed in suggesting that a game
like This lends credibility to quote
nonsense politicians have been spewing
for years about video games conditioning
young people now train wrecks might not
be the best Arbiter for what content is
suitable for children and I don't
personally think that the level of
realism is going to be the Difference
Maker in what conditions people but
later in his response he alludes to what
I think is the much more interesting
conversation do we really need any of
this like on record there are plenty of
other violent video games that have
caused controversy because they are
extremely shocking Modern Warfare 2's no
Russian mission where you kill civilians
in an airport is a great example many
felt that the gameplay was too real and
even compared it to similar real-life
events which ultimately led to the
question was that necessary the short
answer is not really the mission was
intended to shock people I mean it even
came with a warning and the option to
skip it altogether during that time
terrorist attacks were a very hot button
issue and the mission touched directly
on people's fears and I think it's the
same with unrecord we've become all too
familiar with police body cam footage in
recent years on record is attempting to
tap into that shock and use that
unfortunately familiar POV as the
backbone of their game have they crossed
the line in doing that well that's the
question to me whether it's necessary or
not hinges on what the Studio's intent
is under a subheading titled pro-police
or anti-police Studio drama stated that
the game has no bias and that audiences
will have to trust the Integrity of the
studio to see what direction they go in
however they also say that the game will
avoid undesirable topics such as
discrimination and racism which is a
very interesting statement now I'm not
going to sit here and act like this is
the first and only game to touch on
themes like this hell even
Counter-Strike is a game that's about
terrorists versus counter-terrorists but
at the same time when I'm playing that
game I'm not thinking about killing
terrorists or planting bombs I'm
thinking about my individual performance
and my team winning will it be the same
for unrecord or is it too close to the
Bone now to be fair there are plenty of
other very popular games that have a
similar goal even narrative driven games
like The Last of Us features disturbing
realistic Gore that is intended to be
shocking hell some people said that they
would flat out never touch a game like
this but I was playing Cod the other day
and I mean that game's pretty damn
realistic too some of those takedowns
feel like war crimes is the level of
Gore and Estelle takedown in the last of
us are Modern Warfare 2 really necessary
to the overall game no not really but it
is there nonetheless and with a game
like unrecord it seems like we're taking
another step in the direction of ultra
realistic violence but to be fair to
them
there's clearly a market for it
so the Studio's name is drama they
haven't done any other game to my
knowledge I'm curious if drama was I
don't know intended that's a
tongue-in-cheek name for the studio
studio drama causing drama